All right, we got somebody named Zero
Logic on the stage. How you doing? Yo,
can you hear me? Yes, I can hear you.
How's it going, bro? How's your day,
David? Pretty good. Pretty good.
Blessed. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, bro. I'm just
letting you know uh I'm a Muslim and uh
I'm a big fan of you. I watch like I
really enjoy the show. I can't lie.
That's pretty cool. Yeah, I see the
topic is Paul is greater than Muhammad.
Obviously, I disagree. Can you provide
like can you like navigate the
conversation? I have nothing in my head.
I I would ask why do you disagree? Why
why do you disagree? Firstly, cuz I
would say Muhammad was a messenger who
came with his own uh book, his own
scripture like Jesus and Moses.
Paul wasn't a disciple of Jesus. He was
an apostle of Jesus who received
revelation and wrote scripture. Matter
of fact, he wrote 13 books of the New
Testament. I think if I'm not mistaken,
13 of the 27 he wrote. Oh, okay. We can
move on to miracles. Okay. I would say
uh all perform miracles. Muhammad as
well. What miracle did Muhammad perform?
Um we have couple of examples. Do you do
you count prophecies as miracles? Um
uh I I think that's in it in a different
category honestly. Okay. performing
miracles is like a supernatural act that
that is done like a healing or I don't
know something you know splitting water
prophecy is more so giving knowledge or
revelation of the unseen yeah I can say
splitting of the moon can we say that
okay you could say that where where does
the Quran say that Muhammad split the
moon uh it's it's not in the Quran it's
in the hadith I think okay that's
actually true but then there's a hadith
narration that says that he split the
But for the Quran, it records it
differently. The Quran says,
"Behold, the hour is nigh. The hour is
near, right? Judgment day is near and
the moon is split a sunder." So the moon
being split is supposed to be a sign of
the judgment day coming. So if Muhammad
split the moon, but judgment day didn't
come, it was nowhere near, that would
mean that the Quran is given like a
false prophecy or something. So So yeah.
So you're saying that the splitting of
the moon is the sign of the hour. So, so
since it happened and that didn't come,
that's wrong. That's what you think.
Yeah. Now, I don't think that the Quran
puts the moon splitting as like a a
miracle, but just a a sign of the hour.
Like, for example, Jesus says when the
the hour is coming, the the the sun
would be red and the moon will be
darkened. You know, he says stuff like
that. Or I'm sorry, in reverse, the sun
will be darkened and the moon will be
red, right? Like these are signs. And he
says these are signs. when you see these
signs, that's how you know the times are
approaching. And um I think the Quran
does it similarly. It doesn't say like
it's a miracle like it's not saying
Jesus is turning the moon red or
darkening the sun, but these are just
signs of the end times on its way. Okay,
but you can correct me if I'm wrong, but
I remember that he he split the moon and
the the companions were with him and it
was like a miracle.
That's what the hadith says. The hadith
says that there that he actually split
the moon while the Quran says that he's
just a warner and that Allah doesn't do
any miracles uh through him because the
the people just believe anyway so he's
not going to do any miracles and so that
would contradict what the Quran says
like the Quran says he's not going to do
any miracles but hadith says he does
some miracles and so that's that's a
confliction there. Can you can you uh
break down the verse in the Quran that
says that no the the last prophet will
not do miracles? Yeah. Yeah. Let me see.
We got we got chapter we got quite a
few.
17 I think it's 59. 179.
Yeah. I'll put on the screen. Okay. So
1759 right there it says, "And nothing
has prevented us from sending signs
except that the former peoples denied
them and we gave Talmud the sheic camel
as a visible sign but they wronged her
and we send not the signs except as a
warning." So Allah, so they're in
context, they're asking Muhammad to
perform a miracle and he Allah responds,
"Nothing prevents us from sending signs
except that the former peoples denied
them." So because people in the past
disbelieved in the signs that Allah sent
anyway, he's not going to send signs
anymore into this generation. Okay. So
in context, this is talking specifically
about the prophet Muhammad, right? 100%.
Okay. Can you take me through uh a
miracle of Paul? Sure. Sure, sure. Sure.
So, we got quite a few miracles of Paul.
Let's see here.
Um, wait. So, so from what I know, Paul
came I I thought he was one of the like
the disciples and Jesus himself was the
prophet in Christianity. Is that not
true? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Jesus is who is
the divine son of God who sends Paul as
his apostle to spread the gospel spread
the angel to um
non-Jews. So okay um so that's what Paul
so Paul is a messenger of God who is
empowered by God to preach and to also
perform miracles showing that he's sent
by God. Okay. So uh let's see here I
forgot. So, is there no difference
between Paul and Moses? They're both in
the same category. Um, well, yes and no.
Like, yes and no. Like, both like Moses
is empowered by God to give the
revelation of God and do miracles and so
is Paul. So, technically, yeah, they're
like in the same boat, you know.
All right, let's see here. Trying to see
if if we can get if I can get a list or
do I just have to do this? Like, we can
go just through like one or something. I
I just want to see like what the the
criteria is to like validate America or
something like that. Yeah. Yeah. I gota
I gota Okay. All right. All right. So,
Paul healed a man who was crippled from
birth. We got Acts 14. Let's pull this
up really quick. Acts 14 in the Bible.
So, this is in the the revelation that
Paul revealed, right? Acts 14. Acts is
written Acts is written by Luke and he's
given the history of Paul and the church
really not just Paul but the church as a
whole. And so here he's talking about
he's recounting when Paul did miracles
in Lististra. Okay. Okay. So here we go.
I'm sorry. Can you can you elaborate
quickly on the the like the difference
between like the four books like the
Luke and Matthew and and and Paul
himself? Like what's the difference?
Yeah. So, Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John,
they wrote the gospel that Jesus was
preaching. They wrote the gospel down.
Okay? Um Paul wrote letters to the
churches and believers after Jesus
ascended and as the church is being
formed and growing, Paul is writing
letters to churches that are inspired by
God for him to for for people to be
guided on how to live, right? what's the
right things to believe, how to handle
certain situations within the church and
within the Christian community. And so
he's writing letters on Christian living
and Christian doctrine, what you what
you believe like Akita. Okay. So, so you
have like the New Testament is wrote by
the four that you mentioned and Paul
wrote letters, right? Yes. Yes. Okay.
Thank you. Thank you. Can you continue
with the All right. So, here we go.
We've got ourselves here. Acts 14
starting in verse 8 it says, "Now at
Lististra there was a man sitting who
could not use his feet. He was crippled
from birth and had never walked. He
listened to Paul speaking." And Paul
looking intently at him and seeing that
he had faith to be made well, said in a
loud voice, "Stand upright on your
feet." And he sprang up and began
walking. And when the crowds saw what
Paul had done, they lifted up their
voices saying in
Lysanian, "The gods have come down to us
in the likeness of men." So they begin
to worship him and other and Barnabas.
Barnabas they called Zeus and Paul
Hermes because he was the chief speaker.
And the priest of Zeus, whose temple was
at the entrance of the city, brought
oxen and garlands to the gates, wanted
to offer sacrifices to the crowds. But
when the apostles Barnabas and Paul
heard of it, they tore their garments
and rushed out into the crowd, crying
out, "Men, why are you doing these
things? We are also men of like nature
with you. and we bring you good news
that you should turn from these vain
things to a living God who made the
heaven and the earth and the sea and all
that's in them. So he tells them to stop
worshiping them. They're just men. Tell
them to stop worshiping him. Okay. So So
in terms of uh miracles, okay,
that's clear miracle. Yeah, he did many
he did many miracles, man. There's
there's he did many miracles. Yeah.
That's what what else can qualify what
else can qualify someone to be a
prophet? I don't know. I just thought
about miracles. Well, yeah, that's
that's a good point. Uh miracles or
prophecies really them being affirmed by
other messengers of God or other
disciples, right? You know, you can tell
that they're preaching the same. They're
in line with the prophets that came
before them, right? So, they're they're
consistent with what came before them.
They're not contradicting the previous
prophets and stuff, the previous
messengers. And so what we have with
Paul and witnesses, witnesses to their
revelation and to their prophethood and
stuff like that. So you have Paul has
witnesses, right? He has witnesses. He
has uh disciples that and messengers of
God that affirm that he really did
receive revelation from God and he's in
line with them. So he's not a lone wolf.
He's he also has affirmation of the
other apostles of Jesus like Peter,
James, John. So he has that going for
him, witnesses and uh you know me being
attested to by messengers of God. He
performed miracles, right? Showing that
God really did send him and then he's
consistent with what came before him,
right? He aligns with what came before
him. Okay. So these are clear signs that
someone is truly sent by God as a
messenger. Okay. Okay. I'm sorry. And in
the first point you said you can't you
would not say the same thing for the
companions of the prophet Muhammad that
he had people affirming him or uh Yeah.
Yeah. The reason why I wouldn't say the
companions of Muhammad would equivalent
to that is because they're not
messengers of God, right? They're just
his companions. They're just people
around him. And so the difference is
that Paul has other messengers of God
affirm him like say yeah he had he
received the same revelation that we
received you know so you have the you
have the apostle Peter the apostle James
and the apostle John who all were with
Jesus. James is the brother of Jesus. Um
they received the holy spirit and was
prophesying and preaching and performing
miracles. Um, so these people also
affirmed that Paul was in line with
them. Okay. The the Sahaba of Muhammad,
they're just regular guys. They're not
inspired by God, right? They don't
they're not receiving revelation and
stuff like that. Okay. And the others
that you named count as messengers in
Christianity. Yes. Are do you have any
idea if these are characters in Islam?
And do you have any Arabic name or
something? I I think Arabic name. Oh
yeah, sure. So Peter would be I think
Simon or Shimon. Okay. Um John is
Johanna. Yeah. And Paul Paul is Bulis.
James I don't know. I don't know what
James is in in Arabic. I don't know what
James is in Arabic. I'm sorry. Yes. So
he's basically confirmed by by
messengers more than Yes. Exactly.
Exactly. Okay. I understand. Thank you
so much. Yeah. For sure. Nothing else to
say. Thank you. Uh, thank you for having
me on. I'm a big fan, bro. I watch you.
Well, thanks for joining, man. Think
think think about what we talked about
because this is this is really
important. If if Paul has all of this
working for him, then this does
demonstrate that, you know, Jesus is
Lord and the gospel is true and Paul's
writings are true and we got to pay
attention to that. Yeah. I I I just uh I
just didn't know about the the the
difference between like the New
Testament and the letters of Paul. I
didn't know like where kind of like
where to start reading but now I like I
think I have like a clear idea. Yeah. If
you if you want to start reading start
reading start reading the Gospel of
John. Start reading the Gospel of Jesus
according to what John wrote. Start
there first because there it gives you a
clear picture of Jesus and who he was
before he even came and was born of a
virgin. how he is the word of God who
was with the father from eternity's past
existing and fellowshipping with the
father before he came and took on flesh.
So John's gospel explains that pretty
good. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, bro. Thank you
so much. Uh I I appreciate your passion,
bro, and like the way like I'm I'm a fan
like I can't lie. Like I'm a fan of like
your your intellect and your passion
like when you're giving things. I'm I'm
born Muslim from Egypt by the way. Nice
to meet you, bro. That's pretty good.
All right. Well, yeah, nice to meet you,
too. It was a pleasure talking to you,
my friend. Thank you. Thank you. Take
care, bro.